à l'appel de force ouvrière et de la cgt
pour dénoncer les conditions de travail
une cinquantaine de soignants se sont
réunis devant l'hôpital de rambouillet
mercredi 31 mars
clémentine autain député la france
insoumise de seine-saint-denis et
candidate aux élections régionales en
île de france a tenu à être sur place
même si la santé n'est pas une
compétence de la région
c'est très difficile arrive à la
troisième vague qu'on est vraiment d
équipe épuisée qu on donne notre maximum
pour la première deuxième troisième
vague que on se mobilise au niveau de
nos plannings de notre vie personnelle
qu'on donne le maximum qu'une fois que
la crise qovu défini on doit rattraper
tous cas pas été fait au niveau du bloc
opératoire et que la sa du commence à
devenir très difficile dans cet hôpital
au moment de la manifestation sur les
douze nuit en réanimation existants ont
été occupés par des patients
si dans un hôpital vous n'avez pas plus
de lits en période normale que ce qu'il
faut ça veut dire que à la moindre crise
vous êtes en état de saturation et donc
c'est pourquoi j'en veux aux
gouvernements successifs d'avoir
supprimé par dizaines de milliers des
lits d'hôpitaux en france parce que
c'est ce qui nous a rendu si fragile si
faible dans la crise depuis mars dernier
la députée a échangé pendant plus de
deux heures avec les soignants écoutant
leurs revendications elle a été à
l'écouté de nos revendications je pense
que c'est quelqu'un qui va remonter en
fait toutes les problématiques que tout
le monde connaît et je pense que c'est
quelqu'un qui est relativement fidèle
dans ce qu'elle fait puisque jusqu'à
présent tout ce qu'elle a essayé de
mettre en place bien elle l'a fait je
pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a
véritablement des convictions et ça
c'est important
les élections régionales se dérouleront
normalement les 13 et 20 juin 2021